so i know this guy
who was dating this girl
i know this guy who is dating a girl
and the girl it was not
uh it was not um you know it's kind of
casual
just dating you know a guy that was
dating a girl not casual casual
they're not an item they're not even
going out anymore um
but it turns out that the girl is
pregnant
is that real yeah wait wait wait wait
wait
and it turns out that once he broke up
you know the guy i'm not going to say
the guy
yeah but he was freaked out he was
freaked out but it turns out that once
he stopped dating her
she dated somebody else and they they uh
tracked it back to he's not the father
right
but that has not been confirmed yet with
it's confirmed
we know it but he doesn't know that he's
not the father how does he how do you
know
that he doesn't know because i know the
guy and he's freaked out
okay she's gonna call the guy uh we
should call the guy i was gonna call the
guy
as the girl's father but he knows your
voice no
he doesn't know yours oh you want me to
do it
yes okay so i gotta write down the the
specifics so what's the girl's name
you're right
so give me give me the girl's name and
give me the
father's name and i just had her tested
and asked him what his attend
his intentions are you know you just
found out you know
i gotta write it down i gotta write down
let me know but you don't read the
scripts
you just [ __ ] with it when it happens so
what's the girl's name
uh what's the girl's name i don't know
you're sending it to me okay
you can put it up the girl's name is is
bailey bailey
yeah so you're bailey's dad you could
say who you you know you could say
uh so uh does he does this guy know
bailey's dad's name
would he know no so could you could use
bobby i would say howard
uh she she might think it's a joke
because she does know
that they know howie mandel so if it's a
prank he wouldn't know he works with me
so just say you're bobby i'm bobby
robert
okay bobby's just too childish for a
father
well robert robert um hello let's
rehearse real quick
yeah hi um my name is robert i'm
bailey's father
yeah hi my name is robert
and i'm bailey's father oh thank you you
got notes
um i want to say that uh bailey didn't
think it was you but i took her to our
doctor for a dna test
and it wasn't who she thought it was she
was only with one other person and it
was you
yeah um she is now five weeks long
yeah five weeks and then the funny thing
about pranks is just
leave it to him yeah i've never done
this before so i'll try
no and so you should say you know and uh
what's his what's his name don't say his
name i don't call his name but you'll
bleep it out jeremy
yeah i don't know if you could say i
think you'd be pretty serious about it
we'll bleep the name out
okay just in case hell you could be the
doctor as a backup in case something's
yeah i'm at you could say i'm at the i'm
at a clinic with bailey yeah
bailey's in the other she won't be able
he won't be able to talk to bailey
because
bailey's uh changing yeah so you just
have talking to mike and i'm going to
dial the numbers it's gonna be the
hardest thing i've ever done okay go try
okay you got it
yeah okay
what's that noise i'm just getting out
oh i thought that was you scratching
your feet
you hear that yeah good
hello hello speaking
yeah hi um my name is robert i'm uh
bailey's father
yes so we were just at a clinic
and um you know bailey didn't think that
you
were the father but it looks like you
are she's five weeks along
okay i don't know how that's possible
why uh we haven't been together since
april yeah i mean i
you know it's like that's what you say
but um
she's like three and a half months along
well you just told me five weeks yeah i
just i got it wrong
okay something sounds a little off to me
well this whole situation's off for me i
i agree
i mean what i mean from i mean listen
this i've never been in the situation
before and either it's bailey
either yeah so now getting a call like
this i'm a little freaked out
i mean we will work it out
okay i just i just i just don't
understand how
if how it could be me if it's
way over that a lot of time it's three
and a half months
but how come i just was told five weeks
when i just said it because i read it
wrong
i have everything down on paper and i
just wrote it wrong i apologize
can you send me that paper yeah i will
okay
um so what do we do from here you think
uh what does she want to do she wants to
keep it
oh my god oh my god
yeah is it are you with her is the way i
can speak with her
she's in the other room we just finished
it so um
you know she should be on about 10
minutes
oh my god i'm in the lobby oh my god
yeah me too man oh my god
do you want to talk to the doctor no no
i don't need to talk to the doctor well
he's coming out now
no i don't i don't need to talk to you
okay all right hello
hello hello yeah yeah this is dr michael
who's yeah who am i speaking to you
please
oh uh you're the um i i was
speaking to bailey's father here are you
the uh you are the father
i i don't know that well bailey is three
and a half months along
um she said that she was with two
different people you being one of them
um the other person submitted to a dna
test that doesn't match so
it's the only the only explanation is
you um the good news is it's a girl
and um very healthy girl
pardon me i mean yeah i i don't need to
have all this information unless well
let me just tell you
what it is it's a beautiful little girl
and
um she is just uh stunning we heard the
heartbeat would you like to hear the
heartbeat
no no no no i want to see proof
oh um well is there any way that i i can
give you 100 proof she's
bailey has kind of told us that she was
only with
two people one i understand but i have
the dna test
i need to see physical proof well sir
this is your daughter i mean i don't i
need to see physical proof
i don't want to get involved in this i'm
just a doctor do you want to i'll put
her father back on talk to your
father-in-law
and uh wow
hello hello yeah
um listen you know in this situation
we're taking it one more
moment at a time and we will get you the
proof i mean you know yeah i definitely
want to see proof
yeah but i mean like i i would also like
to talk about hypotheticals here
well i don't want to talk about anything
until i see proof
okay well regardless if we get the proof
or not
right she's keeping the baby
listen we will get you the proof right
but we are keeping the baby
and so i would just like to see what we
can do hypothetically because
it looks like all the proof
it looks like it's your baby
okay so what's your hypothetical here
you know um i mean bailey does have
feelings for you
so maybe you can jointly raise the baby
maybe get married i mean i don't know
what the situation
all right i need to see proof before i
go along with anything here
okay hello it's dr michael again
yes yeah uh so you'd like to submit for
a dna test
no i would like to see proof well if you
give us your dna i will show you i will
match your dna no no
no that's that's not the way it works i
need to see proof that how far along she
is well we are going to um
bailey's father here said that there is
a possibility of
uh nuptials so we have to take a blood
test and that in order to get a license
i don't know why you're
what happened what do you mean what do
you think happened he hung up yeah
no we don't have to we don't we don't
have to call back
anyway thanks for being honored bobby
you don't feel bad about that you've
been uh
you don't feel bad about that you've
been a terrific guest today
bobby lee well thank bobby sponsors
jackie you did a great job i'm gonna
call it until
next time this is our podcast
[Music]
now